[Music]  first you must ask yourself are you  wealthy super truth of the world is that  most games someone to win someone has to  know  [Laughter]  think of this as fairytale that actually  happened there's confusion over who has  to pay so they drowned Joe and plenty  other innocent people and somebody's  making money from it no it goes back to  this law firm mossack fonseca so what  happens next what do we do next  [Music]  same money it's a scam that goes from  Houston to the West Indies to some bank  who knows where they're gonna weigh with  murder which is bad  big bad it's such a big word for being  such a small  how does it all work bribery corruption  money laundering millions and millions  and millions of dollars  somebody has to sound me along  [Music]  [ __ ] is my money most of the time we  don't even know  [Music]